i talked to vanessa she said the cats
are doing really good she sent me a
video of easy you want to see
what what
messy boots of the week award goes to
miss debbie let's go ahead and give her
a round of applause because
she knew what she was doing did you know
jess had an issue with vanessa
hey my 90 day fans fam it's melicia
so much went down on the latest episode
of
happily ever after angela's doubts about
a future with michael
hit a new high after her doctor revealed
her biopsy results
and we finally learned what or
should i say who sparked the big fight
that's been teased
between colt and jess over vanessa let's
go ahead and update you on the biggest
must-see moments kicking it off with
miss debbie
who played instigator by revealing
suggests that vanessa
has been at their house taking care of
their cats
while they've been in brazil i talked to
vanessa she said the cats are doing
really good she sent me a video of easy
you want to see
what what
i said vanessa told me the cats are
really doing really well and she sent me
a picture
vanessa's watching the cats while we're
gone
she's just watching the cats well you
don't like her
by mentioning her then it's my cat she's
watching my couch for me she's not doing
it for him
so jess is upset for one colt lied
he said that he does not talk to vanessa
anymore which we all knew was not the
truth but she didn't
and for two she thinks that cole and
vanessa are friends with benefits
which she isn't totally wrong about
vanessa i've been more than just friends
i had sex with her
just one time and honestly i have a
crush on her
i think she's a great girl but i don't
think she returns the favor
oh colt well if you thought all miss
debbie was going to do in this situation
was just
light the flame no she continued to fan
it
but if you're that jealous of him and
not trusting him you have a real problem
young lady
i think we have trust issues guys i
don't know why you can't trust him you
don't have a relationship you're gonna
have a real problem that's happened
before
you either love me and you trust me and
you feel secure in our relationship
you don't love him and trust him you
don't have a relationship or you don't
kill a child and you need to grow up
well i don't want to talk more about the
[ __ ]
well as you could see miss debbie didn't
allow colt to get in
too many words so he stepped outside to
share his thoughts
i know i lied to her but right now
vanessa he's just a good friend
and i've been nothing but faithful to
jess i can't help but think back
to larissa and i and i just can't
believe all this is happening
again i think for the first time i'm
seeing just for who she really is
she's not just an innocent go-lucky fun
girl she actually hides a lot of demons
okay trust me i get that dress can be
a bit too much i do but to cut her some
slack
she did just find out that her boyfriend
who she's just been parading around
brazil
has clearly been lying to her and on top
of that
when she found out she got double teamed
by him
and his mom so let's be fair colt
we can't put this all on jess miss
debbie did play a huge part in it
e.t spoke with miss debbie and colt not
too long ago
and we asked her what is it that she
really has against jess check out what
she had to say
i don't trust her sorry i'm sure she's a
nice person in her own way i just don't
think that she'd fit the cold i think
they're so opposite that
it's not a good match
okay well moving on to our final musty
moment
which goes to angela she received great
news from her doctor
she does not have cancer but
on the downside she did reveal the very
very very slim chance of angela
having a successful pregnancy she also
mentioned the dangers
that she would face if she tried
if i can't have a baby you won't marry
me right you know i don't want anything
to happen to you
i'm concerned about it but i can't give
you an answer right now
michael's 22 years younger than me if
michael really wants a baby
well i really don't want him to miss out
on that in his life but i also don't
want him wasting my time either
so he needs to know before we get
married if he wants a baby morning wants
me
[Music]
angela all right well next week on
happily ever after
timbers rise after jess
calls vanessa
hey what are you talking about vanessa
talking with your friends you talk
every day look at this i can't read it
fine
wait jess
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because we are covering it all see you
next time
you